welcome to all of you to this session on
evolution control and its applications
my name is Jennifer Decker I have been
working in Wolfram technology group for
about two years now
so in Wolfram language every expression
has a generic form so it will have a
head then it will have elements and each
element will have sub head sub elements
and so on so an expression looks
something like this so it is a bunch of
heads and elements so let's look at some
examples for example this expression as
you can see so this fits in with the
generic expression here and even simple
looking expression such as an assignment
or a composite expression so they can be
represented you are in this generic form
and even graphics objects they have this
same form so it has a head it has
elements and then sub heads of elements
and so on
now Mathematica has a well structured
evaluation process and it is kind of
interesting and useful but it is also
little difficult to understand but if we
want to appreciate the true potential of
Wolfram language it is good to
understand this so if we understand this
we can understand our more sophisticated
programming features such as delayed
evaluation of said delights coping
abilities or plot table etcetera and we
can also write angels programs and
custom functions and so on so I'll be
discussing these three topics so the six
step evaluation process some application
examples and finally working with
unevaluated expressions so let's begin
so this is what happens when we type an
expression and hit shift enter or safe
return so in the very beginning
Mathematica will evaluate the head of
the expression so for example here we
have this head
so Mathematica evaluates this to plus
and then it evaluates 30
similarly here so we have a list of
consents and our head it takes a the
first element from this function so it
picks sign and then it evaluates the
result and we can see the steps are
using trace so as we can see it
evaluated this one first it took out the
first element sign and then it evaluated
it in the next step our four standard
evaluation it will evaluate all the
elements in the order given all in
non-standard
evaluation it will evaluate only
selected elements so let us see what I
mean by this so we have this expression
here so again in the first step it
evaluated this variable but here there
is nothing to evaluate but then in
continuing on evaluating each of this
element so it evaluated print fives then
print to print three similarly here when
we use plus so it is as you can see it
is evaluating the arguments in time now
in non-standard evaluation it a
mathematical does not evaluate all the
arguments and let us see why this
becomes important in certain cases so
for example we have this plot function
if plot evaluates the arguments then
this becomes four so then mathematical
would just give a flat line like this
two squared so that is not what we want
so that's why there are certain
functions where the evaluations are not
done for all the elements for example
our another example is stable so if we
have a global variable X table does not
evaluate this argument otherwise we will
just get for in all over the places
similarly for the if statement but I
won't go through the details here for
now
okay so we have these three attributes
by which we can control which elements
are to be evaluated the so this is how
we can set attribute C attributes and
clear attributes so we can set
attributes using set attributes we can
check the attributes using the
attributes Monson and using clear
attributes we can clear certain
attributes so with the whole first
attribute Mathematica would not evaluate
the first element so for example we have
our X s 1 Y is 2 Z as 3 and we have set
hold first for F 1 and as you can see it
did not evaluate the first argument but
it evaluated the other arguments with
whole rest it will evaluate all but the
first element as you can see here it did
not evaluate y&z but it evaluated X and
with whole all it won't evaluate any
arguments now
in step 3 it will apply some
transformations according to these three
other attributes order less listable
and flat so let me go through these
attributes briefly so what order list
does is that it breaks the order of the
arguments given by the user and
rearranges the arguments rearranges it
as needed
so for example we have this magnified
image function which takes an image and
it magnifies the image by a certain
factor now as you can understand so okay
so this is our function this is our
image original image okay so now okay we
are using the function the first
argument is our image the second
argument is our factor so this works as
expected but if we reverse the order
here it it does not work right because
for the first argument mathematical
expects an image but if we set orderly's
attribute to the function then it works
in both ways so the order of the
attributes
doesn't matter anymore so that's what
order list does so this is another
example so we have this one son which
expects the first argument to be a
symbol the second argument to be an
integer and the third argument to a real
number but as you can see here it did
not matter in which order we supplied
the arguments although here are in the
definition we are specifying that we
need symbol for the first one and so on
okay and there are some other examples I
won't go through those for now so
listable i think most of you are
familiar with so what it does is that it
distributes the definition over the
elements so as you can see here we gave
a list here and the definition got
distributed to each element here and
listable
is used for many built-in functions for
a sign for example sign log and so on so
so it is kind of convenient so we supply
a list and the list table attribute
automatically distributes the function
over the elements and it does it for
2-dimensional lists and so on okay our
flat I won't go through the details so
basically here the thing to note here is
that certain functions for example plus
x they don't need this nested
occurrences so for example this
statement is equivalent to this one we
don't need this nested inner plus here
similarly for x so for such functions we
have this flat attribute which would
just flatten these nested occurrences
and this does the same job as flatten
function
so this is a quick note about
inheritance of attributes okay the
sections that I'm marking as optional I
won't go through those in details you're
welcome to take a look in in your time
so let us say we have this function f1
which has the attribute hold on now as
you can see it is holding the attribute
holding the element here it is not
evaluating K now we set f2 equal to f1
now if we evaluate this one this holds
the argument although the attribute of
we do not have the hold on attribute for
f2 so this is a quick note and it
happens for all other attributes like
order less flat and so on okay are in
step 4 and 5 our Mathematica will apply
the definition so our custom definitions
will be tried first before the built-in
definition so let us say we have this
definition here and so as you can see
our Mathematica is first evaluating the
arguments then it is applying the
definition and the same holds for
inbuilt definitions as well and as I was
telling the custom definitions will be
tried first so for example here we are
modifying the sine function we are
telling that for sine of PI over 2 we
need n1 and for the rest science would
function as usual so if we see the
definitions associated with sine as you
can see this this definition is appended
here and Mathematica will try this one
first before the general definition
similarly for plus and so on
okay so there are situations where
mathematical can get into infinite loops
and if we know about the evolution
control then we can understand it little
better so for example this simple
statement gets into an infinite loop so
what happens is that Mathematica will
try to evaluate this right-hand side
first then for X it will find this
definition and it enters into that
infinite recursion so it all it keeps on
finding this definition and it tries to
substitute so it goes into an infinite
loop and we have this recursion limit
and iteration limit to control such
infinite loops okay so in the final step
so after applying the custom definitions
built-in definitions and so on
Mathematica will evaluate the result so
what I mean by this is that Mathematica
will not leave anything unevaluated
after it has applied all the steps so
for example here we have the whole roll
attribute for sign so as you can see so
it evil mathematical so in step 5 up to
our in step 5 Mathematica evaluated this
one and then in step 6 it just evaluated
the sign of them so yeah I mean it is
kind of a simple thing so Mathematica
will not leave anything unavailable
whatever it finds it after sigh our step
5 it will just evaluate it all together
so this is an example where we are
showing all the steps so we have these
three assignments and we are keeping
this custom head which is equal to plus
and if we evaluate that it simply does
the summation and as you can see so the
head is getting evaluated first then the
arguments are getting evaluated then
okay I'm suing it yeah the head gets
evaluated first then the arguments get
evaluated and then the ordered this
attribute is applied but we can't see it
using trace
and then step four is not relevant
because we do not have any custom
definitions and then finally Mathematica
is evaluating the result okay also let's
look at some application examples where
our knowledge of evolution control
becomes important so we need to hold an
argument or whenever we need to pass it
symbolically or update it so let's go to
the examples directly so this is a
function for tracking your dynamic
variables on the record points function
so what it does is that it takes a
control object as the first argument and
it takes an empty variable as the second
argument and whatever it will record all
the points visited so I am visiting all
these points and this symbol will record
all these points so on this is same
thing with slider 2d so let's say if we
try to draw a circle here so this
variable should contain those point now
we can apply this plot on it to see the
circle now the important thing to note
here is that we need this whole rest
attribute for this function so let us
see what happens if we do not have this
whole rest attribute okay so in the
first case it should work fine okay it
works fine but it does not work for any
other subsequent runs so what happens is
that now this gets evaluated because we
don't we are not holding it so then
Mathematica sees a list of values it
does not see that empty variable so this
is an example where the whole rest the
hold attributes become important let's
look at this one a colleague of mine
brought it to me a few days ago it is
kind of an interesting example so let's
say here we have a pure function
ah just a table function and we are
feeding random integer to that and as
you can see it is not creating unique
random integers for with this table so
what happens is that on the pure
function it evaluates this argument
first so then it gets a random integer
so in this case it was zero and it is
just creating the table out of those
zeros so to prevent that we have to give
this whole first attribute to the pure
function so in that way so mathematic is
not evaluating it here it is feeding it
to the pure function it is going to the
table here and then it is getting
evaluated as usual so we get a list of
different integers so this is an example
with custom plot function so let's say
we have this global variable X now we
are trying to write a custom plot
function that would generate a plot
using lines and so on lines and points
and so on and so it expects a function
for the first argument and it expects a
range for the second argument and this
does not work and that is because plot
is evaluating this one so it is saying
thousand instead of this function and it
is also evaluating this one so we don't
have the iterator anymore we have the
value so to prevent that evaluation we
have to hold all the arguments so we
give this whole whole attribute and then
the plot work plot see works fine and
this is another example I won't go
through the details okay
let us look at some built-in functions
so table gets the scoping ability from
the hold alt attribute so as you can see
this declaration of the global variable
does not affect the operation of table
because table oan't evaluate this one it
has the as you can see it has the holder
attribute so if we remove that whole
wall attribute so let what we are doing
is we are removing the holdall attribute
and we are giving it whole rest so that
means we are holding this argument so as
you can see here tables
gives our table evaluates this one and
basically it does not work without the
whole attribute and the same thing
happens for plot our plot has the whole
whole attribute without the if we remove
the hold all attribute it will just plot
a single number and so said till it
becomes set without the hold all
attribute so here we have the set
delayed and it works as expected we are
changing the value of x and it if is
getting evaluated differently but if we
remove the hold all attribute of said
delayed then it behaves just like set so
it does not perform that delayed
evaluation anymore absolutely yeah so it
does not do that
delayed evolution anymore okay so in
some cases we have to override those
hold star attributes of the built-in
function so here are a couple of ways to
do it so method one is that we can wrap
evaluate around that argument so it will
force the evaluation so here let's say
we have this function with hold all
attribute and as you can see here it is
not evaluating the argument but if we
wrap evaluate around it then it
evaluates now we can do that using
replace all here is a technique with the
weight function which can do it and this
is known as injector pattern it is kind
of reversed replace all and not go
through the details of how it works for
now and let's look at some examples
where we can apply these methods when
where we have to apply these methods so
this is an expression and let's say we
want to okay let me clear the so this is
an expression and let's say we want to
use this expression inside function so
but this does not work as you can see
this is because um the a pure function
it has the whole whole attribute so it
won't evaluate this variable to this one
so Mathematica is
not seeing this one here so if we wrap
even weight around it then it works as
expected
for the sake of time let me skip this
one let me so this one so let's say we
want to pass a pre-constructed list of
options so let us say for the plot
function we want to set plot points max
recursion and cloud style and we want to
create a list first and then pass it to
the plot function and this does not work
because plot has the holdall attribute
and similarly for other functions like
an intricate if we create a list of
one's a list of options and try to pass
it it does not work but if we wrap
evaluate around those then it works fine
okay something went wrong sorry
okay this does not work and sorry here
here are here you mean okay let's think
okay it does not work out so basically I
think it is not evaluating this one at
all so yeah it is not seeing the options
all right let me skip the other examples
for now let's go to the unevaluated
expressions so these are some functions
that can prevent evaluation for example
if we wrap hole around an expression it
does not evaluate similarly with hole
form we have unevaluated so this is an
interesting function let me explain to
explain this so your unevaluated does
the same thing as hold but what it does
is that it the head here mathematical
still says the head as plus not
unevaluated so what I mean is that let
us say if we have hold here so in that
case Mathematica says the head hold but
here it says the head plus so that
becomes useful in certain cases we'll go
to the example soon so similarly we have
defer are basically here it does not
evaluate the expression but if we can
copy and paste it and then it works as
the original expression similarly we
have in activate which in activates the
heads now let's look at some examples
where unevaluated expressions can be
helpful so we can find the length of an
expression using the unevaluated so if
we try to do let us say
length of one plus two plus three then
it just returns zero that is because
Mathematica evaluates this one and then
tries to apply the length so it is
evaluating this one to six and then it
tries to apply the length function but
we can get away with it using the
unevaluated function similarly we can
find the length of a variable name so we
need this unevaluated function because
otherwise Mathematica will evaluate this
one so let's say if we have if we do not
have the unevaluated then mathematical
okay so then mathematical converted this
hundred to string and then it returns
the length of the string okay
I don't know why I can't expand it let
me go to work amount so weakens our
extract specific parts from an
expression for example here we are
selecting the real numbers using cases
and we need again unevaluated here
because otherwise Mathematica will
simply evaluate this expression and
similarly we can find the integers and
so on okay
so we'll end with this chart reasons
gives technique so this was invented by
one of our developers so what it does is
that it can do endless evaluation at an
arbitrary depth so let's say we have
this function and let's say we want to
evaluate only this term now we can't use
evaluate here because evaluate does not
work at an arbitrary depth if we wrap
evaluated evaluate around the whole
thing then it will just evaluate the
entire expression we can use some of the
earlier methods like width or injector
pattern but as you can see these are
kind of invasive because we are kind of
meddling with the origin original
expression like we're substituting X
here we are substituting X here and so
on so what this does is that so this is
the technique so it uses on the width
similar to the injector pattern but it
kind of forces that evaluation using
this condition so
yep so it forces that evaluation and
similarly so we can apply to in
different cases for example here we have
this function and we want to apply this
function only to this third term so we
can do it using the technique and
similarly here we are applying that
function to only real numbers so we have
set up the pattern and rest is the
technique and it evaluates fine so this
is a little more elaborate example so we
have expound we have a binomial
expansion here and what we are doing is
that we are trying to evaluate only the
all terms so we have substituted some
values for a and B and we are picking
out the odd terms using odd Q and we
will we are applying the technique to
evaluate only the odd terms okay so yeah
that concludes my presentation thank you
for your attention and if you have any
further comments and questions we can
set up some time and you can send me a
message through possible thank you
[Applause]